4월 2일 한국 시간 기준으로 오전 2시 40분이고요
오늘 국장 요약하면 약간 이 짤이 가장 적절한 것 같아서 갖고 와봤습니다
국장이 이제 승리를 이뤄냈죠
트럼프도 생각나고
총수님들께서 힘을 합쳐서 국장을 지켜냈고
코스피가 무려 8.4%나 오르는 그런 아름다운 장이었고
현재 시간 기준으로 나스닥은 미국 시장은 지금 진행 중인데
나스닥 1.7% 상승하고 있고
다우 0.8% 그리고 S&P 500 1.13% 상승하고 있습니다
전부 좋은 장이죠
그리고 이제 야간 선물
요즘에 이제 야간 선물을 많이들 보시니까
코스피 200 야간 선물은 2.78% 상승 중이고
코스닥 150은 1.52% 상승 중입니다
제가 지금 또 여행 중이에요 아시다시피
그래서 이탈리아에 있다가 스위스로 왔다가 지금 프랑스
제가 이제 어제 주가가 오르기 시작한 게
제가 오를레양이 있으면서 이제 오르기 시작했는데
베르사유 공전으로 넘어오면서 또 주가가 올랐어요
그래서 기분이 좋고
베르사유 드립을 어떤 걸 칠까 생각을 해보니까
같이 간 사람들이 코스피 몇 배로 사요 이렇게 드립을 치라고 해서
제가 드립을 치려고 한 건 아니고
제 친구들이 드립을 치라고 해서 이렇게 칩니다
코스피 몇 배로 사요 몇 배로 사야 되나
멀티플을 그래서 한번 좀 봤어요
사실 PBR로 코스피 멀티플을 많이 보긴 하는데
귀찮아서 PER로 갖고 왔습니다
그래서 대충 보면은 4월 1일 장 시작 전 기준으로
포워드 퍼로 봤을 때 얼마나 기업이 이익을 버느냐
향후 12개월 기준으로 봤을 때 가장 낮은 순간이다
그래서 제가 지금 지금 지금 지금 지금 지금 지금 지금 지금
어떻게 보면 코스피가 저평가된 부분들이 물론 있지 않나
물론 리스크가 있으니까 최근에 저평가가 된 거긴 한데
그래도 아 뭔가 한 달 전 1년 전과 비교해 봤을 때
코스피가 저렴했고 뭐 그런 것 때문에 올랐겠죠
싸면 살수록 뭐 어느 정도 모아가는 전략 나쁘진 않은 것 같아요
다만 여전히 리스크가 있기 때문에
이제 얻어맞을 준비도 하면서 보유를 고민하시는 게 좋을 것 같고
그리고 제가 파리로 이동했거든요
그래서 에펠탑도 사진을 찍었는데
비가 와서 에펠탑 사진을 제대로 못 찍었습니다
어쨌든 파리니까 오늘 주가도 올랐으니까
파리 투나잇 하시고
또 원유가 올랐으니까
원유 가격 보면 WTI 기준으로는 1.62% 하락했고
브랜트 기준으로는 2.57%
다행히 다시 이제 100불 언저리로 좀 내려왔습니다
물론 많이 떨어진 건 아니에요
어쨌든 그렇고 어떤 일들이 좀 있었는지
전쟁과 관련돼서 업데이트를 해보면
트럼프가 또 트럼프다운 일들을 했습니다
월스틱 저널에서는 이란과 말싸움을 했다라고 하는데
어떤 얘기냐
트럼프가 SNS에 글을 올렸어요
어떤 글을 올렸냐면
이란의 새로운 정권의 대통령이 방금 미국에 휴전 요청을 했다
이렇게 올렸습니다
자 그래서 이게 본문이고
어떤 얘기냐
이란의 새로운 정권 대통령이 미합 중국에 휴전을 요청했다라는 얘기를 하면서
호르무즈 해업을 개방되고 자유롭게 통행할 수 있을 때
이를 검토할 것이다 라고 얘기를 하면서
뭔가 휴전과 관련된 얘기를 진행하고 있는 듯한 뉘앙스의 이야기를 했고
이게 시장에서 좀 긍정적으로 받아들여진 것 같습니다
그런데 이 글이 올라오자마자 또 어떤 답변이 있었냐면
이란의 형령수비대에
이제 얘기가 나왔는데
이란의 형령수비대는 호르무즈 해업에 대한 통제권을 계속 유지하겠다라고 얘기를 했죠
그러니까 트럼프의 말과 좀 상충되는 얘기를 했고
더군다나 트럼프의 얘기가 연출적인 행동이다
그러니까 이란을 석기시대로 만들겠다
뭐 이런 표현을 트럼프가 했는데
이런 게 너무 배우적이고 연출적인 행동이 아니냐
일축을 했습니다
그래서 트럼프의 의견에 대해서
그리고 이란의 외무부도
이란이 휴전 요청하지 않았다라고 밝혔습니다
그래서 이란의 외무부도 이란이 휴전 요청하지 않았다라고 밝혔습니다
이란은 이걸 부정하고 있고요
저도 기본적인 생각은 여전히 비슷해요
제가 어저께도 약간 좀 페이크다라고 봤던 거는
대화가 진행되고 있는 건 맞는데
이란의 상황과 트럼프의 상황은 분명히 좀 다른 것 같습니다
트럼프는 휴전을 하고 싶은데
또 타코를 했는데
이란의 형령수비대에서 뭔가 입장이 나와야지
사실 의미가 있는 거여서
저는 대통령이 이렇게 좋게 말하는 건
어차피 이란의 대통령은 원래부터 완화적인 사람이어서
이게 뭔가 진정하게 전쟁을 좀
가라앉히기는 좀 어렵지 않을까
물론 계속 왔다 갔다 하겠죠
왔다 갔다 할 것 같은데
진짜라고 믿긴 좀 아쉬운 부분들이 있다라고 생각을 합니다
그리고 또 스페이스X 관련된 뉴스가 좀 흥미로웠는데
스페이스X가 다른 경쟁사들보다 앞서서
IPO 신청을 했다라는 그런 뉴스가 블룸버그에서 나왔어요
그래서 스페이스X IPO에 대해서
개인적으로 갖고 있는 생각은 뭐냐면
스페이스X가 사실 상장할 때
아마 시가총액을 1.75 트릴리언 달러
스페이스X가 사실 상장할 때 아마 시가총액을 1.75 트릴리언 달러
정도로 받으려고 한다라고 알려져 있는데
이렇게 되면 사실 어마어마한 유동성을 빨아가야 되거든요
주식시장에서
그래서 전쟁과 별개로 상당히 변수가 될 것 같아요
주식시장에서 유동성을 너무 많이 빨아가
굳이 비교를 하자면 우리나라에서 LG 에너지 솔루션이
코로나 상승장에 한가운데서 IPO를 하면서
어마어마한 유동성을 빨아가지 않았습니까?
스페이스X도 좀 비슷한 부분이 있는 것 같고
스페이스X 같은 경우는 사실
스페이스X가 IPO를 하고
또 엔트로픽이나 오픈 AI가 IPO를 하게 되면
2026년 기준으로 가장 많은 신주 발행을 하게 되거든요
미국 주식시장이
이게 유동성에 저는 솔직히 좀 안 좋은 영향을 줄 것 같아서
그런 부분들이 좀 많이 걱정이 된다라는 말씀을 좀 드리고
이건 좀 더 IPO 날짜가 나오면 제가 업데이트를 해 보겠습니다
그 외에 오늘 마이크론이 11%나 오르고 있는데요
마이크론이 사실 오르는 거는 기술적 반등이다라고 보시면 될 것 같아요
그러니까 마이크론이 원래 400 한 몇 십불까지도 갔다가
지금 최근에 엄청 많이 빠졌는데
그거에 대한 좀 바운스백이다
그거를 기술적 반등이라고 보시면 될 것 같아요
기술적인 반등을 하는 상황인데
어떤 뉴스가 있었냐면
켄터 피츠제럴드에서 마이크론의 투자 의견을
목표 주가를 700달러 그리고 탑픽으로 유지하면서
되게 세게 센 리포트가 나오면서
오늘 마이크론이 좀 반등을 했습니다
그래서 켄터 피츠제럴드에서는
최근에 우려들이 좀 문제가 없다
그런 얘기를 했었어요
그래서 이 세 가지 얘기들
최근에 디램 시장에서 있었던 세 가지 악재가 있었거든요
그거에 대해서 좀 반박을 했는데
하나는
현물가가 하락하고 있다
이걸 반박을 했습니다
근데 이 디램 현물가 하락 자체가
이제 리테일 시장
소비자 시장에서 나온 건데
이 소비자 시장에서의 하락은
사실 마이크론 매출의 5% 미만이다 라는 거죠
그러니까 사실 최근에 시장은
소비자들 B2C 시장에서
디램 가격이 하락을 한 건데
사실 디램 가격의 상승은
대부분 AI 데이터 센터가 주도했기 때문에
이런 게 좀 매출에선 큰 의미가 없다라는
그런 얘기로 보시면 될 것 같고요
그리고 오픈 AI가
과잉 출하와 관련된 우려에 대해서는
오픈 AI는 사실 법적인 계약을 한 적도 없고
그래서 재고가 쌓일 것도 없다
시장에서는 이제 갑자기
메모리 재고가 쌓일 거 자체에 대해서 걱정하는데
애초에 오픈 AI가 뭔가 법적 구속력 있는 계약을 한 것도 아니고
그거에 맞춰서 메모리를 만들었던 것도 아니기 때문에
재고 과잉 우려가 없다라는 얘기를 했고
또 하나는 구글이 터보 퀀트 관련된 논문을 썼죠
근데 이거 자체도 제본스의 역설
효율화되면 될수록 더 사람들이 많이
쓸 것이다 라는 그런 얘기를 하면서
최근에 이 세 가지 때문에
사실 메모리 업체들이 많이 하락을 했는데
이 세 가지가 문제가 없다라는 그런 얘기를 반박을 했습니다
그리고 또 하나의 전쟁의 변수가 찾아왔는데
바로 아랍에미레이트가 좀 열이 받은 거 같아요
그래서 호르무즈 강제로 개방하겠다
나도 좀 군사적으로 참전을 할 수도 있다라는 얘기를
아랍에미레이트가 하면서
이게 또 걸프 국가들이 본격적으로
정말 호르무즈에 나서는 건가 이런 얘기가 있습니다
사실 아랍에미레이트 입장에서 좀 빡칠 만도 해요
상당히 많은 공격을 이란으로부터 받았기 때문에
그리고 또 호르무즈의 해협에 피해를 보는 것도 맞기 때문에
이런 전쟁 참전 의사에 대해서 얘기를 했고요
이게 또 전쟁의 변수가 될지는 좀 두고 봐야 될 것 같습니다
자 그리고 캠피셔가 계속 최근에 글을 올려서
그 글을 좀 가지고 와 봤어요
캠피셔가 비즈니스 타임스에 새로운 글을 기고를 해서
캠피셔 글도 간단히 좀 보면
이런 지정학적 분쟁이 있을 때
시장의 반응은 3단계 패턴이다
라고 얘기를 하죠
자 이 3단계 패턴이란 게 뭐냐
전쟁이 되기 전에 유가가 오르면서 주가가 하락을 하고
그리고 2단계로 넘어가면
전쟁이 이제 일어나고 나면
최악의 시나리오를 주가에서 다 반영을 한다
이미 최악의 경우를 3개월 앞서서
6개월 앞서서 시장이 전부 다 반영을 해 버린다
그게 2단계고
그리고 3단계가 되면
막상 전쟁이 시작되고 나면
경제 충격이 생각보다 제한적이라는 걸
시장이 알게 되고
세상이 망하지 않는구나 라면서
주가 반등을 하는데
캠피셔는 이게 지금 2단계에서 3단계 사이에 와 있다
라는 얘기를 하고 있고요
그리고 호르무즈 해업 붕쇄에 대해서
사람들이 많이 걱정하고 있는데
이것이 과장됐다 라는 얘기를 합니다
자 호르무즈 해업을 통과하는 물량의 3분의 1은
원유가 수출되는 게 아니라 아웃바운드
그러니까 중동에서 나가는 물량이 아니라
정제 가공을 위해서 중동으로
걸프 지역으로 들어오는 인바운드 물량이다 라는 거예요
다시 들어오는 물량이기 때문에
호르무즈 해업을 통과하는 세계 석유 공급의
20%다 라는 말 자체가
수치가 좀 과장됐다 라는 얘기를 하고 있고요
자 그리고 사람들이 이제 고유가가 성장을 죽인다
라는 얘기를 하지만
2023년도에도 배럴당 75달러
고유가가 지속이 됐음에도 불구하고
세계 주식시장 나쁘지 않았다
라는 얘기를 하고 있습니다
그래서 캠피셔 여전히 가끔 물어보시더라고요
캠피셔 생각 긍정적이냐 물어보시는데
긍정적이다 라는 얘기를 하고요
자 그다음에 또 긍정적인 뉴스 하나 또 있죠?
세계 국채지수, 선진국 지수에 편입이 됐어요
그래서 이게 선진국만 들어가는 그런
약간 국채지수 같은 건데
이제 세계 국채지수에 편입이 되면
패시브 국채 자금이 많이 들어옵니다
그러면 한전을 하고 싶어 하는
그런 에너지가 많이 강해지겠죠
그러면서 외화 자금이 한국으로 좀 들어오는
긍정적인 현상이 일어난다 라고
요약을 할 수가 있을 것 같고요
그래서 좀 긍정적인 뉴스 말씀을 드리고
아 근데 뭔가 개인적으로 여전히 불안해요
전쟁을 근본적으로 바꿀 수 있는
뉴스까지는 아닌 것 같다 하지만
사실 또 이미 도망갈 거면 이미 도망가든가
사실 지금 정도 처맞았으면
제가 보기에 그냥 끝까지 한번 버텨봐야 되는
상황까지 오지 않았나?
뭐 이런 생각을 하면서
물론 제가 또 틀릴 수 있으니까
또 잘 도망가신 분들도 있고
또 사팔사팔 잘하시는 분들은
또 그런 식으로 플레이를 하면 될 것 같습니다
그럼 저는 또 다음 영상으로 찾아뵙겠습니다
감사합니다